un termómetro en un laboratorio muestra
la temperatura en celsius 100 fahrenheit
si el mercurio en el termómetro marca 56
grados fahrenheit cuál es la temperatura
correspondiente en celsius y aquí nos
dan dos fórmulas una para pasar de
celsius a fahrenheit y otra para pasar
de fahrenheit a celsius de hecho se
puede obtener una de la otra utilizando
un poco de álgebra y de hecho a lo mejor
puede hacer un vídeo más tarde para
explicar de dónde salen estas fórmulas
otra vez eso necesita un poquito de
álgebra pero bueno ahorita nos dan las
fórmulas y basta saber aplicarlas y para
saber aplicarlas tenemos que saber pues
cuál tenemos que utilizar notemos que
nos están dando la temperatura en
fahrenheit nos están dando que f efe es
igual a 56 a 56 y lo que nos piden
determinar es ce y precisamente la
segunda fórmula la segunda fórmula aquí
tiene la f es decir a partir de una
temperatura en fahrenheit y una
temperatura en fahrenheit nos permite
obtener una n
grados centígrados entonces vamos a
utilizar la segunda fórmula nos quedaría
lo siguiente nos quedaría que c es igual
a 5 novenos 5 novenos df - 32 osea de 56
menos 32 56 menos 32 56 menos 32 es 24
así que esto es igual a 5 novenos 5
novenos de 24 24
que es igual a 5 por 24 5 por 24
dividido entre 9 entre 9 y aquí antes de
realizar la operación 5 por 24 voy a
simplificar un 3 notemos que 24 y 9 son
ambos divisibles entre 3 entonces puedo
dividir entre 3 el numerador y dividir
entre 3 el entre 3 el denominador 24
entre 3 me queda 8 9 entre 3 me queda 3
de esta forma esta fracción es igual a 5
por 8 es 40 5 por 8 es 40 y abajo nos
queda 340 entre 340 tercios y para
entender este número un poco mejor
podemos realizar la división de casita
déjame tomar el color azul y aquí vamos
a dividir 40 entre 3 para obtener un
número un poco más éste que nos diga un
poco más entonces 40 entre 33 caben 4
una vez una por 3 6-3
4 - 3 es uno baja este 0 3 caben 10 3
veces 3 por 3 9 10 menos 91 aquí hay un
punto decimal entonces puede bajar otro
0 bajo otro 0 y aquí sería punto decimal
3 cabe 3 veces 3 x 3 9 y aquí bajaría
otro 1 10 menos 9 es 1
entonces pues aquí siguen bajando ceros
y aquí siguen apareciendo 13 vale
entonces sería 13.333 3 3 de esta forma
40 entre 3 es lo mismo que lo podemos
escribir así 13.3 y ponemos una barrita
aquí arriba indicando que se repite
periódicamente que hay que poner 333 33
esto es una forma de escribirlo pero
también podemos escribirlo como que 40 o
más bien como que 3 cabe 13 veces y
sobra una sobra una es decir nos
quedamos aquí y entonces podemos
escribir esto como un número mixto
podemos ponerlo como 13
un tercio 13 y un tercio todo esto es en
grados centígrados grados centígrados
muy bien entonces esto nos dice que 56
grados fahrenheit es 13.3 periódico o
bien 13 y un tercio grados centígrados